(quick drum beats)
(lively music)
- Let me show you
what an athlete
keeping it 100 looks like.
- Well I'm the best
corner in the game!
When you try me with a
sorry receiver like Crabtree
that's the result you gon' get!
Don't you ever talk about me!
(audience cheering
and applauding)
- See?
That...
That's 100.
Right?
I mean, do you know
how scared America was
for that white woman?
Oh my god, woo.
Is faking an orgasm
keepin' it 70?
- [Man] Hello!
- Or is it lying?
- Well that's.
- And why am I asking you right?
- It's keeping it, first
of all I don't know
what you're talking about.
(audience laughing)
But second of all I'd
say it's keeping it 70.
It depends though.
If you're not enjoying
the sex at all
and you're faking it,
that's, you're Marshawn
Lynch-ing at that point.
(laughing)
- All you have to do is spend
a month with Donald Sterling.
(audience member laughing)
Hold on!
- Okay.
- At his summer house, okay.
And he never calls
you Sherrod, okay?
- Oh fine yeah, done.
- He only refers to you as
"that's my (bleep)
right over there".
(audience ooh-ing)
Hey America.
Larry Wilmore here.
If you like The Nighly
Show on Comedy Central,
like us on Facebook too.
Just don't poke me.
I do not like being poked.
You can Candy Crush me.